Tinsley does client
confidentiality mean nothing to you
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be my
full She-Hulk Episode 5 video there were a whole
bunch of Marvel Easter eggs and references lots
of Deadpool X-Men references even Fantastic Four
Easter eggs there were also a lot of Daredevil
references to setting up next week's episode
it seems like next week's episode will be the
Daredevil episode so we'll break it all down
I'm doing videos for all the episodes if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get them obviously there's a bunch of big
Marvel stuff coming up and they just have the
d23 panel made a bunch of big announcements I'll
be doing videos for all that stuff too careful for
spoilers for the episode if you haven't seen it
I will just start at the beginning and work our
way through shot by shot talking about Easter eggs
and WTF moments and the Bonanza of Easter eggs for
X-Men Fantastic Four Deadpool stuff that they
had in the episode like every X-Men character
that you want to see in the MCU was referenced
during this episode any tips on getting into
the MCU there cork like what is going on here
do they already exist in the MCU is this what
they're telling us like is this why She-Hulk is
referencing them because why would she be doing
that if they didn't already exist in the MCU so so
many theories just exploded after the end credits
scene this episode but the actual title of the
episode is Mean Green and straight poured into
these genes is a reference to she-hulk's dating
profile on the Tinder joke version of the MCU app
called matcher which he winds up using to win
her case against Titania the episode is mostly
a She-Hulk vs Titania episode but they also set
up the person who's making her superhero costume
and he's kind of like the She-Hulk version of
Melvin Potter in the Netflix Daredevil series
making all the superhero outfits which is also
where we get our Daredevil reference too like we
find out that he's making Daredevil's new yellow
costume which is why I say Daredevil is probably
going to be next week's episode because like
at the very end they end with that tag scene
showing Daredevil's costume in Titania is like
a long time She-Hulk villain in the comics but
the way they're using her in the MCU is like
the most thought version of the character ever
she's like the queen of thoughtlandia in the MCU
like the worst version of an influencer peddling
all kinds of fake snake oil health and beauty
products that you could possibly imagine you can
make all kinds of real life references like who
is it she's directly parodying here like pretty
much every terrible influencer on Instagram and
Tick Tock that you can think of a lot of weirdo
thoughts out there like this selling fake Beauty
and supplement products on Instagram and Tick Tock
the actual opening scene is of Titania's fake
advertisement she creates for her bogus Health
Products and supplements line she's peddling using
she-hulk's name to get back at her for beating her
ass in court literally like physically beating her
ass and to cash in on her name recognition because
she became super popular overnight when the video
of her circulated on social media beating her ass
you notice throughout the episode like she's kind
of trying to Peddle herself as a fake version of
Shield wearing those green clothes some of the
weird supplements that she's trying to sell
the beauty products are green themed even though
they kind of joke that they're basically the same
product just repackaged and renamed as different
things they make a lot of snake oil references so
you could also make a Captain America serpent
Society joke if you want to because this whole
episode is just riddled with all kinds of Easter
eggs and references to different big Marvel comic
book properties when she's driving through Los
Angeles most of these locations that they show you
are actually real locations in La like she's on
Sunset Drive here driving past the billboard near
Chateau Marmot I haven't been there personally
like it's not quite as big as people think that
it is but it is a long time celebrity haunt
also her billboard here mentions her products
are available at the pop-up store at The Grove
that is a real-life Los Angeles shopping center
that you can go to which she does go to later in
the episode also the funny thing here too if you
haven't ever lived in Los Angeles Billboards
like this are very common so even though it's
meant to be a joke in the episode there are giant
Billboards like this up and down Sunset Boulevard
that they'll put stuff like this on periodically
you notice she's calling all of her followers on
social media titaniacs which is ironic because
she's kind of a Maniac also on the flip side
she-hulk's whole thing is using her rage to Hulk
out she winds up having to explain the situation
to her cousin Chad who is a total idiot the way
they play him in the scene thinks that she's the
one selling the products because they got her name
all over them which you see him in the end credits
scene actually peddling the products like he said
he was doing I'm making a killing off of all these
then they have a new custom version of the title
scene intro where the She-Hulk logo changes to
the pink Titania version of the logo also with a
different Titania version of the She-Hulk theme
song with her speaking over the end of it she's
got this whole infuriating fake Valley Girl accent
way of speaking I don't know if that's fake in
the context of the MCU like she's just faking
all this and she speaks differently because she
is in later episodes so we'll see if her voice
changes in later episodes when she actually starts
literally fighting She-Hulk but like I explained
her whole thing is being the Uber thought of the
MCU look the Thanos level thought on planet Earth
this actually looks like a real pop-up I've
actually been to a lot of these in real life
and they are funny kind of like this they make
the snake oil reference like the whole idea is
that she's selling all these fake products just
repackaging them and making them sound different
but she's charging people a bunch of money for
it getting super rich off of it they're actually
a lot of people that do this in real life like so
these weirdo products and supplements and Beauty
lines and get super rich off of it later at the
office Josh Zagara's pug asked Nikki to help him
snagging some of the new Iron Man 3 shoes that are
being released there was an advertisement for them
on Jennifer Walter's browser in an earlier episode
and in the trailers during the Daredevil episode
when you see him show up and they start going at
each other she's wearing her comic book accurate
suit which they give her in this episode you also
see her wearing Hulk colored versions of the Iron
Man 3 shoes and obviously the shoes themselves
are meant to be a reference to the Iron Man 3
movie so it sounds like Nikki is the person who
gives her the extra pair of the She-Hulk shoes
or pug gives her the extra pair of the She-Hulk
shoes that he gets we also find out that puck is a
huge sneaker fiend and collects a bunch of special
edition sneakers in the end credit scene when they
reveal all the X-Men the Deadpool the Fantastic
Four Easter egg sneakers in the background that's
meant to be his closet that they're in like Nikki
is visiting his place and seeing his collection
of limited edition sneakers don't worry explain
what all these are references to like all the
different characters the X-Men Fantastic Four
Deadpool characters they reference at the end
of the video there's like so many characters they
reference in the scene it'll probably take me like
half the video just to explain every single one of
them when he calls this special drip broker Alonso
obviously it's this character here but the name
is a reference to Victoria Alonso who is a real
life Marvel employee who's like one of the most
powerful people at Marvel Studios under Kevin
feige she's in charge of all their post-production
that they do on the movies and the Disney plus
Series so you see her in a lot of the premieres
and some of the behind the scenes that they put on
the home video releases Shield breaks the fourth
wall to comment on Titania's social media account
that also exists in real life Marvel actually
created real Titania profiles on all the major
social media platforms like Twitter Instagram
Tick Tock with the actress posting content on
them as if she were the real Titania just sassing
on She-Hulk the joke here about the Boba shop is
also a funny shangshi Easter egg too in real
life the shangshi actor simu Liu actually just
started a real Boba business on the side in the
same way that a lot of celebrities in real life
start their own small businesses on the side
apart from their acting jobs inside there's
another QR code that you can scan to get another
free She-Hulk comic book and they have this huge
joke about him peddling all this bootleg Avengers
merchandise with all the logos and the colors just
being a little bit off they also play like
a slightly different version of The Avengers
theme song like this isn't quite the Avengers but
it's close to the Avengers the mugs say Avengers
with an O we actually see a version of that mug
in the end credits scene with her holding it up
in evidence so they might use that in a future
episode or it might just be a funny thing that
they included for the end credits they flipped
the whole colors they flip the Iron Man colors
the Thor mug says Thor instead of Thor with an O
they wind up walking away having to buy some merch
wearing it and then they tell all these lies about
Jen already being in Avenger in order to get the
appointment with Alonso later in the episode they
talk about the paperwork still being in progress
that's actually a real life reference to She-Hulk
eventually being in Avengers 5 King Dynasty and
Avengers 6 Secret Wars like they're referencing
that Marvel is still working out the deal the
paperwork for her to come back as She-Hulk in
future movies which she will of course that's
why they keep making references to her being an
Avenger during the episodes at her Law Firm they
bring back the Mallory book character who is a
comic book character who also works at the GLK
and H Law Firm that She-Hulk works at in the
comics like this is all a comic book thing but
in the comic she's just a normal person she
doesn't have any special powers or anything
like that the whole idea during the episode with
characters yelling at her about the trademark for
her She-Hulk name and her being comfortable using
the name on a regular basis is just setting up the
idea that she will eventually just start to think
of herself as she hooked normally like the other
regular Avengers characters think of themselves
they make more doctor strange and Thor Avengers
references claiming and this is a true fact
that they didn't have to actually trademark
their names because those names that they use are
their real birth names they're not pseudonyms like
that's actual real legal thing when Titania calls
She-Hulk Shrek that's actually a joke that people
have been using in real life like ever since the
shield trailer started dropping people have been
making Fiona references saying that she looks kind
of like Fiona just because of the way her special
effects look compared to the regular Bruce Banner
Hulk special effects and you have to remember that
they filmed this like last year so like long
before they started releasing the trailers and
people started making the Fiona Shrek jokes about
She-Hulk they were actually making this joke in
the episodes when they're at the courtroom Mallory
book references the Bruce Banner Hulk again and
she breaks the fourth wall again when they show
footage of her complaining about the She-Hulk name
she does it again at the end of the proceedings
just to react to the judge's request for more
evidence then when they walk into alonso's shop
some of these in the background might be comic
book Easter eggs I couldn't find any direct
references so if you think you know what this
mascar and some of these clothes in the background
are references to post it in the comments most of
the direct comic book references to like Daredevil
all that stuff doesn't happen till later in the
episode code I believe the glasses on the woman
here is more of an Edna Mode Incredibles reference
Disney also owns Pixar now too they actually
had another Pixar reference in an earlier shulk
episode 2. they referenced her origin when saying
she's related to the Hulk by Blood like she's
first cousins with the Hulk and she also literally
got contaminated with his blood when he rattles
off a couple different types of costumes the fire
resistant one is a reference to Johnny Storm of
the Fantastic Four waterproofing is a name War
reference and the built-in Weaponry is a Wolverine
X-Men claws reference like his claws are literally
built into his body so his costume has to account
for that if you include the other Wolverine Easter
egg in the post credit scene with the special
shoes there have been three Wolverine references
on She-Hulk so far the Tinsley character's name
is a reference to an actor who was shown up on a
bunch like many many different Marvel series and
movies and the She-Hulk episodes recently is the
bar Patron like there's an actor who's an extra in
all the Marvel movies the TV shows named Tinsley
who just show shows up all over the place kind of
in the same way that Wong now shows up all over
the place when she sees one of her bad dates Todd
show up at the law firm as a client she gets the
idea to use the Tinder style dating app matcher is
the evidence she needs to win the trial they even
make a couple of death by snoo snoo jokes in her
profile like she jokes about looking for a match
that has a strong back in a sturdy large bed so
like she's DTF and ready to kill you by snooze
new it'll hurt but you'll enjoy every second of
it one of the horniest Marvel series that we've
had so far one of her bad dates makes a pass at
Titania on the way out of the courtroom which he's
like okay sure whatever let's go do it you can buy
me stuff she breaks the fourth wall again after
Mallory agrees to celebratory drinks with her and
it's funny how tiny she looks in that larger suit
like you don't get the perspective until you see
her standing next to Mallory in Jennifer Walters
form like she is Tiny she breaks the fourth wall
again when she remembers that her new superhero
outfits are done and when she tries on the regular
looking business suits that he created for her
the little something extra that he references is
her comic book accurate purple and green suit when
she says she won't have the occasion to wear the
superhero suit he also picks up Daredevil's yellow
helmet in a box like this is literally Daredevil's
helmet that we see in all the trailers and he
passes by Daredevil's new costume on Iraq here
like this is Daredevil's rack and he's creating
suits and a new superhero suit for him too that
he's coming to pick up the tag is also yellow and
red for Daredevil colors and because the episode
ends on this moment I think this is basically them
just telling us that the Daredevil episode is next
week's episode six like a confidential client
is coming to pick this up in next week's episode
so the whole idea is that Daredevil got his new
suit from this guy too like Melvin Potter style
this guy just created another superhero costume
for him and that's probably how they explain it
being yellow with a stark contrast in red the
suit does look exactly like his Netflix suit
too like it's the same suit which is a little
bit of yellow on it instead of this the solid
red and black I'm kind of wondering if they're
gonna have a joke about it during the episode
who were like She-Hulk jokes about it being too
contrasty like why do you want to stick out so bad
if you're being a vigilante on the DL don't you
want to hide and that might Inspire him to get the
black costume from the comics like the Daredevil
Back in Black costume or the solid red one that
they'll have during the Daredevil Born Again
series they actually just debuted a brand new logo
for Daredevil born again and it's like his comic
book logo that he wears on his chest he's supposed
to come back during the echo episodes next year
before Daredevil born again and I believe when
he comes back on Echo he'll also have another
different suit it might be like the back in black
suit I'm assuming he'll get a new version of the
solid red one also sometime during Daredevil born
again when those episodes happen then during the
end credit scenes the new scenes that they added
to the actual end credits are Titania and one of
her fake ads in the poster she was signing at her
pop-up earlier in the episode there's a scene
of Chad hustling The Shield products that he
was talking about for Titania that he'd be making
all that money it turns out her boss was secretly
using the booty boost smoothie that she had been
selling because apparently he just wants more junk
in the trunk one of these Associates at the firm
is side eyeing him as he walks by like what then
we get the end credit scene that everybody's going
to be talking about for like the next week like
all the X-Men all the Fantastic Four the Deadpool
everything that you could possibly imagine here
like every major character that you want to see
in the MCU we find out the Pug winds up getting
his Iron Man threes that are themed like Iron
Man's armor in the background just calling these
out as many as possible the purple and green
ones with the pumpkins are Green Goblin shoes
the orange and blue Rock looking ones are for The
Thing from Fantastic Four beneath it on the right
are Vision shoes below that are Captain Marvel
next to her are the Cyclops X-men shoes from top
to bottom on the left side of the Shelf at the top
it starts with regular Bruce Banner Hulk shoes for
purple and green to the left the Flaming red and
white shoes are actually for the classic Falcon
costume beneath that there's Nova shoes there
have actually been rumors of them doing a Nova
Disney plus series to the left are the Ghost
Rider shoes with the flames in the chain the
ones with the orange the green and the wings are
Namor shoes because the wing things on his feet he
actually has those in the Black Panther wakanda
forever trailers the yellow and blue ones above
the thing seem like Wolverine Shoes these are
for Thor the green yellow and white ones might
be for rogue's costume also X-Men I'm not sure
who the solid yellow ones are for they could be
for like Iron Man's classic gold armor they're
not a solid yellow costumes in Marvel when they
zoom out and you see a whole bunch more on the
bottom right you see Spider-Man shoes with the
spiders on them beneath those the white ones but
the moon on them are for Moon Knight on the far
left you see doctor strange shoes I think the
brown and red ones are for the door milage the
green and yellow ones with the lightning bolt are
for Quicksilver also X-Men up on the top right the
purple and red ones are for Magneto the yellow
red and white ones might be for Daredevil could
be for Yellow Jacket there's Captain America ones
beneath him are the Deadpool shoes with his mask
down below Cyclops the solid black ones are for
Black Panther and then there are a couple more
but they're just a little too blurry to spot
any particular Easter egg so if you think you
spotted any references in the other shoes that
I didn't mention in the video just write them
Below in the comments but the whole idea is that
these are meant to be like core X-Men characters
like the ones that you want to see Fantastic Four
characters Deadpool characters obviously and the
whole idea is like we know we're getting Deadpool
3 we know we're getting a Fantastic Four movie and
the closest we've gotten to actual X-Men in the
616 MCU universe is them mentioning Miss Marvel
is a mutant and playing the X-Men the Animated
Series theme song we did get X-Men Easter eggs
during Doctor Strange Multiverse of Mattis but the
whole idea in this post-credits scene is that pug
was able to buy these collectible shoes meaning
that somebody knew about these characters like
these are based on characters that are supposed to
already exist so it's almost like they're saying
in this She-Hulk scene this end credits scene
these are characters that already are in the MCU
you can post all your theories about that in the
comments below like how is it that somebody knew
all these characters existed because these are
all based on their comic book accurate costumes
Shield is meant to be a super meta Series so I
think you could look at a couple different ways
people will be talking about this for a while
though like are these all Canon now like does
this mean that Magneto that Wolverine are already
in the MCU also the new pop song that they use in
the end credits is about saying their name
like the whole episode is about she-hulk's
name itself and the other big difference from
previous episodes here the other notable thing is
that there is no actual post-credits scene we've
gotten post credit scenes in every single episode
so far except for this one I'm assuming that there
will be some sort of Daredevil post-credits scene
in his episode because why wouldn't you have a
daredevil post credit scene if you spotted any
other Easter eggs and references in the episode
that I didn't mention in the video just write
them Below in the comments in my full She-Hulk
episode 6 video will post next week after they
release it my house of the Dragon episode 5
video will post on Sunday and big reminder
the Star Wars Andor episodes also start next week
that'll be on Wednesday so those videos will post
the day before I post my She-Hulk episode videos
Everyone click here for my new Marvel Thunderbolts
First Look teaser video and click here for my
house of the Dragon episode code 5 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!